[موسيقى]
مرحبا يبدا غدا عرض مجموعه جديده من
مسلسلات رمضان 2023 تتنوع ما بين الاكشن
والتشويق والكوميديا والدراما السعيديه
اعمال النجوم كبار تتكون فقط من 15 حلقه
وتاتي بديله لاعمال اخرى من 15 حلقه ينتهي
عرضها اليوم اكثر من مسلسل هيبداوا يوم 16
رمضان وفي مسلسل هيبدا يوم 21 رمضان مسلسل
يوم 21 رمضان هو مسلسل حرب ومسلسل يعني
برضو الدراما وطنيه حربيه لمحمد فرج واحمد
سقفا اكيد طبعا الناس هتبقى منتظره فاعتقد
ان الجمهور هيبقى منتظرهم وغير صحيح ان
الجمهور هيبقى مشغول بالاعمال اللي ممتده
طول رمضان لانه دائما في فرص عن طريق
المنصات ان الناس تقدر تتابع الحلقات بشكل
مجمع الاعمال المرتقبه دراميا في النصف
الثاني من شهر رمضان تحت الوصايه لمنى زكي
جت سليمه لدنيا سمير غانم الصندوق لاحمد
داش تغيير جوله من شلبي ثلثه لغاده عبد
الرازق وكشف المستعجل لمصطفى خاطر ومحمد
عبد الرحمن اعتقد ان النص الثاني من
شهر رمضان هيشهد عرض اعمال مهمه انا يمكن
اكتر عمل مستنيه بشكل كبير جدا هو مسلسل
تحت الوصايه للفنانه منى زكي لانه
البرموهات اللي اتعرضت للعمل بتنب ان احنا
قدام عمل تقيل قضيه جاده موضوع شيق اتمنى
انه يكون كده ويمكن منى زكي لما عملت لعبه
نيوتن من سنتين وحقق نجاح كبير جدا
فالجمهور حب ان هو بيشوف منى زكي في دراما
رمضان في السنين الجايه ظهورها بعمل السنه
دي اعتقد احنا كلنا مستنيين عشان بطل
الحنان
المركب اتسرقت ودي هتعرف مكانها ازاي
يالهوي يا سناء خليكي مكانك ما تتحركيش
[موسيقى]
في المقابل ما الاعمال اللي ينتظرها
الجمهور وماذا يقول عنها
الشريره كلنا لازم ننام على المخده طيبين
ومبسوطين